Goffin here um today I'm going to spray
a little bit from language learning I'm
going to talk about mobile learning and
the fact that there is apparently a move
afoot by UNESCO to develop some
guidelines from mobile learning and the
reason I know that is because I'm on
this list serve of English teachers
which is a community of English teachers
who send out emails on topics and the
topic that they're talking about now is
this your next got UNESCO guideline for
mobile learning before i get into that
let me just say that I played golf today
it was a beautiful day here in Vancouver
three evenings ago we had guests over so
my wife made Dravid locks which is this
scandinavian salmon in which and she
always makes far more than we ever need
so we've been eating the grabber locks
for three days and she made a dough sikh
guy which is black bean chicken and then
she made a risotto with that and so for
the last three days we've been eating
this grabber locks the davao cgi risotto
and she also made a tap tap time which
is a french upside down apple pie so if
eating eating that for three days and of
course with the gravid locks you have to
have a little bit of danish active eat
so you know we've had the same
essentially diet for three days but it's
very delicious and it's lovely now
unesco mobile learning so unesco wants
to have some kind of guidelines for
mobile learning you know when i saw that
i said to myself like if there's one
place where we don't need unesco it's in
mobile learning everything useful that's
going to happen in mobile learning is
going to come from individuals teachers
entrepreneurs learners people who are
going to be developing the technological
aspects of it the pedagogical ass
it's of it the social interaction
aspects of it link is one example of a
mobile learning and and you've got the
creativity of people creating mp3
players and I'm sure that in countries
like India and China they'll come up
with cheaper versions of this and if
everything has to conform to some kind
of UNESCO guidelines well first of all
it won't happen the only thing that will
happen is that there will be a lot of
people employed at UNESCO and a lot of
their favorite consultants will be get
fat contracts to do Studies on stuff
that is all essentially useless and you
know it is time that we we had a
revolution in education you know if you
read back in history in the 17th century
of the you know predominant you know
source of GMP in the country was the
court of Louis quatorze or of whoever it
might be I mean half the manufacturing
in the country one way or another was to
supply the the court and the nobles and
all these people and today a significant
percent of our GM b goes to supply
bureaucrats and officials and people who
travel the world attending conferences
or travel within the country attending
conferences and put out papers which
they translate them and it's all useless
mostly I shouldn't say all but
overwhelmingly useless and what it does
is it dramatically increases the cost of
education it increases the burden the
public debt of countries and we're all
laboring most countries are laboring
under this very large public debt
because they're feeding an inflated
public service that has you know is far
larger than it needs to be and typically
with entitlements that it shouldn't have
and we need to start saying no education
is very important if we're looking at
economic growth if we're looking at what
people want in life you know
they're not going to want 15 cars per
family people don't want necessarily
more material things although perhaps in
India and China to do but in the
developed world they don't my people
want entertainment they want education
they want computer programs they want a
lot of this sort of soft products
Facebook I phone you name it and this is
this this is where innovation is going
to kick in it's not going to kick in yes
there will be some innovation affecting
how we create energy there will be
innovation coming up with better
building materials and that's so forth
and so on and that's fine but there's
this enormous sector which right now is
dominated by the public sector education
health and so forth whether we choose to
fund education or health publicly or not
that's a different issue and I am
largely in favor of funding education
and health publicly so that everyone has
a chance however the delivery of these
services should be deregulated you know
it's like when I try to enter someone in
the language teaching industry in in you
know the Internet as a model for
language learning well you know who what
are their credentials of your teachers
what system do you what pedagogical
system is it doesn't matter people will
learn people learn when it comes to
languages of course if you're training
engineers and you're building bridges
and houses and you have to meet certain
standards and stuff that's one thing but
if you're talking about enriching
people's lives through education let let
people be free to educate themselves
through reading through whatever
initiatives whether it be you know the
Khan Academy in the United States or
everything that this this is it's got to
be a wide open field for individuals
entrepreneurs learners teachers to to
develop without having to conform to
some kind of a UNESCO imposed
I line Wow when I saw that I said boy
there's a completely useless boondoggle
anyway i just thought i would let off
some steam thank you for listening bye
for now